the latest you mind telling the camera
out who you are what you're doing I'm
Gloria pink and I'm Beverly big and
we're here to serve Pink's hot dogs for
the premiere event in price
customer happy oh I think the secret to
keeping a customer happy is great food
generous portions and consistency over
time our laptops are really yummy and we
have over 35 varieties to choose from
and we've been around for 73 years and
we must be good I think so we saw we see
a huge line every time we drive through
home thank you how do you tell a
customer yes even though you might have
to tell them no how do you help them and
not see them books are our philosophy is
the customer's always right so no matter
what and it's not a cookie cutter
operation you don't have to order the
items we have on the menu will create it
and we want we have so many ingredients
there you could put up anything you want
to be there every day of the year and
what's been the most unusual request
oh boy we have a lot of unusual ones but
actually our Martha Stewart dog is very
interesting she waited in line about 30
minutes and came up with her own
creation and it has chopped onions
chopped tomatoes onions sauerkraut sour
cream and bacon and it's yummy did you
know she was coming no she was driving
down the street her entourage and
somebody said what's going on there
there's a big line she said I want to go
in there somebody knew that it was a
legendary hot dog CTN been around since
nineteen thirty nine she waited in line
created her on dog and then we asked her
if we could name it after her and she
said sure in fact she even invited us to
bring 350 Martha Stewart dogs to her
studio and we serve proves to the
audience in New York Times some on your
operation where do they go before they
come to LA what's your website our
website is peace Hollywood calm and you
can follow us on twitter at peace hot
dogs very nice thinking they thank you
so much